James you know I really like how we're
getting immediate visual results from
our code Java scripts fun like that it
runs natively in the browser and it
allows us to run an inspector code very
easily that's something you should be
doing when you're starting out as a
developer yeah it really is by the way
why are we in your github again because
this is where I store my code and I
wanted to get the students thinking
about what it means to save their data
like other programming languages Java
Script gives us a way of saving data in
the form of variables the syntax looks
like this var variable name equals some
value to declare a new variable you
begin with the keyword var regardless of
the data type you're saving and the
example here we're creating a variable
called first-name and assigning it the
string james the string comes in closing
quotes notice that saving variables is
slightly different than python which
doesn't require a keyword like var but
otherwise works the same good point but
otherwise saving variables in Python and
JavaScript are pretty similar numbers in
JavaScript don't need quotes and there's
no need to worry about any of the
nuances between floating-point numbers
and integers because all numbers are
saved as 64-bit floating-point later on
we'll see that arrays functions and even
objects use the same var syntax
let's see if our variables were actually
saved I'm going to add console dot log
first name save this file and reload the
website opening up the console to see if
it shows up and there it is I like that
strategy if the browser opens up the
script with console log in it it'll
print whatever information it receives
to the browser console yep it's a useful
trick for debugging code